it's three common negative for a
solution to the equation 5x plus 2y is
equal to seven so they're saying does X
equal three y equal negative four
satisfy this equation or this
relationship right here so one way to do
it is just to substitute X is equal to 3
and y equals negative 4 into this and
see if five times X plus two times y
does indeed equal seven so we have five
times three plus two times negative four
this is equal to 15 15 plus negative
eight which does indeed equal seven so
it does satisfy the equation so it is on
the line it is a solution x equals 3 y
equals negative 4 is a solution to this
equation so we've essentially answered
our question it is now another way to do
it and I'm not going to go to the
details here is you can actually graph
the line so maybe the line might look
something like this I'm not going to do
it in detail and you see if you have a
very good drawing of it you see whether
the point lies on the line if the point
when you graph the point does lie on the
line it would be a solution if the point
somehow ends up not being on the line
that you'd know it isn't a solution but
to do this you would have to have a very
good drawing and so you and so you could
very precisely determine whether it's on
the line if you do the substitution
method if you just substitute the values
into the equation and see if it comes
out mathematically this will always be
exact so this is all we really have to
do all we really have to do in this
example so it definitely is a solution
to the equation